[Music]
all right so this is my first
non-spoiler review of a movie no
spoilers here don't worry I will not
throw anything away that would ruin the
movie for you I think the first 20
minutes were horrendous I thought it was
humor that I hated from the first movie
and again Deadpool swings out a lot of
different types of humor and I think
half of it works in the first one half
of it doesn't but the stuff I thought
that didn't work in the first one is all
in the beginning of the second movie
they overdo the references to other
comics and all the stuff you saw on
promotions so maybe the promotion's hurt
it a bit but once again this whole x4
storyline and introduce these new
characters stuff that people worry about
might ruin the second movie made it
amazing there's a huge character that
they throw into this movie that you're
not gonna see coming that they hid so
well so make sure you do not get spoiled
about this movie there's a huge shock in
the beginning and the way they promote
this movie they trick you because
there's also in the middle of the movie
a huge shock that happens to a certain
amount of characters that you're like
what all these things cause the audience
to clap and scream and how it loved it
it was so well done and from that point
on when you meet the x-force till the
end it doesn't stop it is action-packed
remember part of this was done by one of
the brilliant minds of John wick so you
see that action effect come into this
movie it's better action in the first
movie cable is a hit the kid with the
fiery hands I am so happy to pick the
actor they did for that because any
other kid actor that would have been
disaster but he's the reason it was
amazing it worked so good and the humor
from after the first 20 minutes on great
no four note they sneak in things you're
like oh they're really going for that
joke and it works and you can tell to
the whole TJ Miller controversy his
scenes were definitely cut down he's
barely in this movie so that's something
that is to turn you from going don't let
it you can tell they're moving on from
him as a character he's basically not
essential to this film and stay for the
post-credits scene
trust me it is the best post-credit
scene you've seen in the Marvel Universe
in the superhero universe it's a treat I
like this movie way better than the
first one and you're gonna see these new
characters really equally get good
amount of screen time they're awesome
all the introductions work and Deadpool
keeps doing this thing in Ryan Reynolds
this is a character he was born for he
owns it
this movie this is his film and they
switch directors on us which I was
worried about cuz I did like the first
movie a lot but this was even better so
it worked out great in the end it makes
you really excited for what's to come
so I'm gonna give Deadpool to a nine and
I suggest to go see it so I hope you
enjoyed my first non-spoiler movie
review I mostly do spoiler reviews but I
want to try something new let me know
you thought down below
you've seen the movie let me know
without spoilers what you thought of it
so don't spoil people haven't and please
subscribe i do reviews a bunch of movies
TV shows I do celebrity interviews as
well and I do fun giveaways with Funko
pop star behind me so hope to see you
next time I keep coming back